but just don't be a dick like don't be a
dick and don't live simple as that the
gift so the gift is written and directed
by joel edgerton I didn't know that
until the end credits came upstairs
jason bateman he's an upstanding guys
got his career he and his wife played by
Rebecca Hall they just got their new
house and Jason Bateman runs across joel
edgerton who plays gordon and they used
to know each other back in high schools
like oh hey pal has gone uh good to see
ya then things start getting weird
because Edgerton just kind of like
intrusive on his life when I was
watching the movie I was like oh yeah
it's just uncomfortable I don't like it
when people intrude on people's lives
just like yeah I did know the boundaries
thing starts kind of getting uneasy and
then kind of hostile and then at a point
you just question the whole thing
because you're like maybe Jason Bateman
has a secret to bullying a psychological
thriller still makes it sound like it's
some sort of adrenaline riot it's a
psychological movie movie kinda reminded
me of one hour photo you have this dude
he's kind of off and you're entertained
to be not a lot of excitements happening
in the movie I tell you this because if
you're going to this movie like yeah I
just got fresh out of ant-man what do we
want to sneak into now man if you're
looking for that charge it's not the
gift but I really dug this movie you
know a movie is actually good when you
get out you're like I like that movie
but I need to digest it a little bit I
love that I love that sensation I
got out of this movie my friend and I
were just talking about it back and
forth on the ride home it's a good
conversational piece movie now you're
talking about it you're peeling the
layers away and you start finding you
more and more and more that you liked
about the movie first of all Jason
Bateman to create this movie comedic
actor most of the time in this movie
you're like oh you mean you've got some
serious acting guts in there you know
we've seen glimmers of that before but
this one was like full-on Rebecca Hall
was great this movie joel edgerton this
dude really committed he's creepy he's
just really awkward you're not supposed
to know where he's coming from this
movie you're not supposed to just be
able to peg him and be like oh that's
that it's supposed to be this element of
grey that's how the movies making you
right it's wave the movie builds tension
really well too I mean there are scenes
where you're like is the outside is he
not and the best part is the movie
doesn't necessarily give you an
explanation as to why yeah I mean you
know why you feel that way is because
how the movie setting it up and you feel
it's like when you go outside and you're
like I feel like I'm being watched right
now I don't know why I feel that way
that's in this movie into the Bravo to
the movies for making you feel that way
and yeah since it's a tension building
movie this movie's not always going at a
sprinting pace not all
is going at a brisk walking pace it just
kind of it walks it's not the fastest
pace movie I got out of this movie I was
like that had to have been two and a
half hours long movie was less than two
hours long now I know that's tension
building in his character building and
you need that in a movie like this but
it really is me nitpicking in the end
the movie is well executed it's a
tension filled movie it's a creepy movie
there's nothing supernatural in this
movie depending on how you lived your
life you might walk out of this movie
thinking I might actually experience
something like that it's possible
there's a huge lesson in the movies that
words have power because things you say
to people hit them make them deep and it
might affect people around them and it
just it might actually do more damage
than just that ha ha just joking think
about what you say man so I will say the
gift is definitely a good time no
alcohol required definitely see it over
the ass-to-mouth that is fantastic human
centipede 4 I saw the gift have you seen
it what did you think about it what's
your favorite creepy guy in the movie
movie you know the movie with the creepy
guy whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
click right here to see more